well when Washington bailed out the
finance world more than a decade ago
after the most recent financial collapse
the government set limits on CEO
compensation and they did it for a
reason taxpayer bailouts should use to
be saving jobs not making corporate
executives richer than they already are
so it's striking by contrast to see the
Department of Education which began
dishing out 14 billion dollars in
bailout funds for American universities
this month is not setting similar limits
on how much university presidents get to
pay themselves and they pay themselves
more than you might think a lot Columbia
University for example is getting twelve
point eight million dollars in bailout
money despite having an eleven billion
dollar endowment the president of that
school a person called Lee Bollinger
makes more than two million dollars a
year in other words Lee Bollinger is set
to collect about one-sixth of the entire
federal bailout Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute is school you probably haven't
heard of and probably for a good reason
is getting four point eight million
dollars in bailout money and amazingly
that's less than university president
Shirley Ann Jackson pays herself every
year so perhaps secretary de Vos can
deposit that money directly into her
personal checking account might as well
the University of Michigan which is a
public school with more than 12 billion
dollars in the bank still got a twenty
five million dollar bailout they plan to
spend eight million dollars on their
football coach this year they're still
gonna lose to Ohio State which got forty
five million dollars in bailout money
that school pays it's coaching staff
eleven million dollars meanwhile the
University of Pennsylvania a school for
kids on the Harvard waitlist received
nine point nine million dollars the
president of u Penn Amy Gutmann makes
nearly three million that's about a
third of the entire bailout if paying
Amy Gutmann is such a priority maybe the
school could find that money in their
fourteen point seven billion dollar
endowment we could go on and on and on
we could cite a dozen examples in fact a
hundred examples young people in this
country are the poorest group in this
country but the schools to pretend to
educate them are the richest
institutions we have
they're getting a bailout the young
people could only dream of
why because universities are one of the
most powerful political interest groups
in the nation and young people are not
and you're not and that's why the
government is blowing billions giving
them cash they don't need at the same
time that you're wondering how to pay
your mortgage now Harvard has announced
it won't be taking bailout funds why
because they spent a week being shamed
in public over it because they have a
forty billion dollar endowment but it
shouldn't take shame for Harvard to do
the right thing they should be decent
enough to do it that's a pipe dream
they're not even close to decent but in
the absence of their decency we need
better laws not a single cent ever
should be spent making rich universities
even richer they do enough harm to this
country